I was at the Golden Globes uh with Mr
guest and I was all done up and I was
wearing a borrowed dress and I was like
walking around kind of like
rubbernecking and trying to be look
pretty and I remember Chris said wow you
know who the most beautiful woman in the
room is and I I kind of thought for a
second not going to happen that Chris
was going to go you and I just kind of
turned him and was
like horrible and he pointed and it was
Jessica t
Andy um and she was sitting by herself
she had gray hair kind of a simple
little Bob virtually no makeup and a
little pink lipstick she was just
sitting at the table like this and he
was right I don't want to fight nature
and it's I have raised in two daughters
and we were raised in an industry where
that was desired to drink off the
Fountain of Youth and I just never
subscribed to it